to build out our UI let's start with the
wireframes for the main activity it
displays a list of forecasts where each
item contains an icon a date weather
description as well as high and low
temperatures for that day since today's
weather is probably most relevant to the
user we give more prominence to it as a
list item compared to the other days
we'll start off by building the list
item layout for future dates because
it's simpler and then afterwards we'll
come back to do the today layout in the
current implementation the list item
forecast layout XML is a horizontal
linear layout of four text views we'll
need to modify the layout so that it
looks like this wire frame we should
divide and conquer until we can use the
view group layouts that we're familiar
with can you imagine how you'd break
down this UI into components that you
know how to build as a hint what if I
draw these separators here within those
elements can you find a way to break it
down even further with view groups
you're familiar with you'll need nested
view groups which means few groups with
children view groups by the way use the
view ID names that we provide an
instructor notes below so that your code
will match ours to verify that the
layout is being built correctly
hard-code some tux values into the
fields such as tomorrow for the date or
clear for the weather condition for
images we can specify a placeholder
drawable called IC underscored launcher
it's named this way because it's the
launcher icon which is also known as the
app icon and this is already included in
our app will be getting the rest of the
weather icons for our App later in this
lesson if you want to see what this
layout looks like you can click on the
design paint to see a preview of it on
the right we see the component tree
listening out the different views we can
also see for a given view what the
properties are and their values you can
change the orientation of the device
that you're previewing you can also
select different devices such as a nexus
7 or nexus 10 you can also preview
multiple devices at the same time as you
build out your layout for this task
don't worry about the font color or font
size or any other visual details until
later after you compile and run the app
should look something like this every
list item has the same dummy data when
you change the layout it will actually
cause a crash in your app
because your code previously assumed
that this list item layout only had one
text view so you need to go to the
forecast adapter Java file and comment
out the lines of code in the bind view
method we're going to fix this method in
a later video